welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alan McHale a professor of history at
Yale University he is an historian of
the early modern Muslim world the
Ottoman Empire and Egypt his work
concentrates on topics in the history of
Empires and environmental history and he
is among the small handful of historians
working in the field of Middle East
environmental history professor McHale
is the author of nature and Empire in
Ottoman Egypt an environmental history
which won the Roger
Owen Book Award from the Middle East
Studies Association the Gustav Ranas
International Book Prize from the
Macmillan Center as well as Yale's
Samuel and Ronnie Heyman prize today
we'll talk with Professor McHale about
his new book the animal in Ottoman Egypt
for which he was again awarded the
macmillan centers gustav Ranas
international book prize for best book
welcome professor McHale thank you very
much for having me so let's talk about
your book what led you to write it okay
so as you mentioned I my previous book
was an environmental history of Egypt's
place in the Ottoman Empire and during
the research for that book one of the
things that I focused on were these
small-scale irrigation projects and so
in reading the work accounts of these
projects I came to see that animals were
involved in various aspects of these
projects so for example bringing
materials to work sites often hauling
materials away sometimes actually
pulling dredges through canals and
things of that nature
so I found that just curious and kind of
clued in to that and having done that I
began to find that there were animals
involved in lots of the kinds of sources
I was reading so another main source for
me for understanding the kind of
agricultural sphere in Egypt were estate
inventories probate
mm-hmm and in those I also found that
animals were a major part of the capital
regime the the wealth accumulation of
rural peoples in Egypt and that has to
do with the fact that peasants
technically couldn't own land so they
owned other other fixed goods and they
owned lots of animals so animals
represented the largest form of wealth
in in the countryside in the periods
that I was interested in roughly 1500 to
1800 so again I started cluing into that
and then I started noticing animals and
all the kinds of sources that I was
reading in different kinds of animals
doing different kinds of things for
different purposes in different moments
in different places and so I became
interested in that and wanted to get
into that topic in more depth and as I
began reading more widely about the the
relationship between the relationships
between humans and animals I came to see
that it allowed me to talk about various
intellectual problems that I was
interested in also okay
and how did you do the methodology I
know we kind of touched on this being
your second visit with us we touched on
it for your first book but let's just
kind of revisit how you did the research
for this book okay
so as a historian you know most of my
research is in archives so I'm in the
most general level interested in Egypt's
place in the Ottoman Empire so that
means two main source bases for me
archival sources one in Istanbul which
was the capital of the Ottoman Empire
I'm in houses the kind of central state
archives if you like for the Ottoman
Empire so all the Imperial orders that
went out communications between various
provinces and the imperial center
matters of of empire if you like so that
was a main source base for me and then
also in Egypt you know the the main
province that I'm interested in there
there are the archival records of
various courts in Egypt so the rural
courts were places that serves various
purposes in rural people's lives
property transactions marriages and
divorces criminal matters the
registering of property probate
inventories that's why I found those for
example so that was a that that lens was
very important for me first seeing what
was going on on the ground in Egypt so
these two source bases together both the
kind of Imperial perspective and the
story of the relationship between Egypt
and the rest of the Ottoman Empire that
I got from Istanbul and then the kind of
rural on the ground if you like
day-to-day affairs of rural people's
that I got from the the court records in
Egypt allowed me to think about how
these kind of small-scale
affairs that had to do with the
ownership of animals or labor matters
how that fit into an imperial framework
I should say also that this project has
various aspects that made it different
than my first book and that I was also
part of the project led me to think
about the trade in animals around the
Ottoman Empire and then also from places
outside of the Ottoman Empire and Egypt
and sometimes to Istanbul as well so
there was a huge trade in animals in the
Indian Ocean so the main sort of
exchange was horses going from parts of
the Ottoman Empire and then also parts
of southern Iran to India and elephants
moving from South Asia from India to
Egypt so because of that that led me to
other kinds of sources manuscript
sources in in India and in Egypt and in
Istanbul to get at this trade in the
Mediterranean I use some Maltese sources
and then also sources from Venice and
then for the later period at the end of
the 18th century and the 19th century I
used some sources from the the that the
National Archives in Kew
in England to help me see kind of some
British imperial interests in these
matters so and then so that's the
archival material and then there was
also manuscript sources from these
various places that I used I use a lot
of manuscript from the by Nikki actually
we have a great collection of mostly
Arabic manuscripts from the early modern
period some in Ottoman Turkish but
mostly in the Arabic materials so
because this topic of the human-animal
relationship was so fundamental to so
much of the function of Egypt and the
Ottoman Empire in the early modern
period and in the 19th century there's a
surfeit of sources for this topic all
kinds of sources both in various
registers you know very local sources
very Imperial sources sources from
outside the empower different languages
etc so you know I enjoy the ability to
combine all of these different kinds of
source materials so let's talk a little
bit about why it's important to look at
the relationship between humans and
animals during this time period tell us
a little bit about it ok so if you think
about a place like Egypt in the 16th
17th and 18th centuries it was a rural
place in which agriculture was central
both to the kind of capital regime of
Egypt taxation to people's labouring
lives right and also to issues of
ideology and imperial sovereignty so
what do I mean by that humans relied on
animals in the countryside to plow
fields to maintain irrigation works to
provide food sometimes in the winters
animals would even brought be brought
into people's homes to as a source of
heat so if they were tied to the daily
labouring lives of rural cultivators in
a place like Egypt and in most other
parts of the world as well and therefore
because of their importance to the
laboring economy there was a lot of
money
tied up in animals so we see that
through these these estate inventories
that one animals represent the largest
share of rural wealth - that they were
involved in very complicated economic
relations so one could for example own
shares in an animal you could buy
futures in an animal Wow
you know we have cases in which someone
owns a third of a water buffalo someone
owns half and did they share it like you
have it for this week you have it for
that way so those shares represented
both sort of pro-rata rights to the
laboring time of that animal right so if
you owned a third of the water buffalo
you got it for a third of the time and
it also represented rights to the animal
products from that animal and then also
you could sell those shares obviously so
I get very complicated relationships of
economy and if you think about again a
early moderate early modern agrarian
society animals were you know the
18-wheelers the motors the sources of
heat the trucks of the society when you
say sources of heat what do you mean by
that well I mean I specifically mean
that they were brought into homes during
the winter right and they snuggled up
with them to keep their bodies produced
provided warmth inside of the house okay
mm-hmm
and also we should say that their dung
served as a source of fuel right they
burned it correct yes yes so so we see
for example that some of the most basic
aspects of the Ottoman economy were
built around the the widespread presence
of animals so what is known as the
chipped in in turkish is the is the the
plot of land that a farmer would would
farm and that refers to the amount of
land that a pair of yoked oxen could
farm in any given day right so the very
definition of property was based on
was based on the labor of animals we see
it also in things like roads are often
defined as having to be wide enough to
allow the passage of animals going on
either side huh
right distances between cities were
often measured in the number of days it
would take a donkey to walk that amount
of that that length so those are just
the in the in the countryside it's also
important to look at and I should say
that those are laboring animals right
some donkeys water buffalos if we look
at a different class of animals in a
different sort of class of society we
see that for example for the Ottoman
Sultans right for the ruling elite of
the Empire animals also played a very
important role in terms of ideology and
then also in terms of if you like King
making so for example hunting right is
very important to the training of the
proper sovereign right it was thought
that lessons of bravery of perseverance
of humility could be learned through the
act of hunting this is a very very old
tradition in multiple cultural spheres
right so you know from China in Central
Asia for kings in Europe etc hunting was
a very important part of sort of making
of a king or in this case assault on
another way this plays out is the
sovereigns created menagerie
so collections of animals that were
often on the grounds of the palace like
what kind of animals so for in the case
of the Ottomans they brought lions and
tigers and elephants cat different kinds
of other large cats birds and and you
know they were it was thought that the
sort of ingathering of the world's the
world's amazing creatures right could
serve as an example of you know the
sovereigns divine nature
to be able to bring in all of all of
these animals on the grounds of the
palace right and so we have also and so
this plays out for example when
ambassadors would come to the ottoman
palace they would often be treated to
you know an animal show in the evening
over dinner right so and this is
something again if we think about even
our our modern our you know modern day
you know the the kind of the example of
you know the Chinese pandas sort of
serving this diplomatic role between
China in the United States who doesn't
love a panda so these you know again and
this is sort of the interesting thing
for me and thinking about the history of
human animal relations was that it is so
fundamental to society economy politics
culture in all periods and in all places
so I mean if we think you know just to
stay in Egypt if we think about sort of
religion in ancient Egypt right the
animal form is very important right if
we think about other religious
traditions in India if we think about
traditions in native North America we
also see that animals play a very
prominent role if we think about our
common day um anyone who has you know
spent time in a park or walking in New
York City will see that the the human
dog relationship is a very important one
you know it's a billion-dollar industry
yes if we think about something like
meat production in the United States all
of these things will see that that you
know humans and animals have been locked
into these very important and mutually
constitutive relationships in all places
and in all times so you know I'm I did a
very small slice of this you know in my
own area of expertise which was the
Ottoman Empire in Egypt in the early
modern period now let me ask you this
you mentioned dogs were their pets in
the not so much in in the upper echelon
of society although I imagine they were
there as well but you know in
agricultural the rural households did
they have pets that's a great question
so you know for modern Americans most of
us do not live on farms and most of our
interactions with animals let's say
beyond consuming them as food is what
historians and people in animal studies
called an effective or companionate
relationship right so pet keeping right
so interestingly and there's been a lot
of literature on this relationship on
how its formed on ideas of domesticity
and how they get played out in this
relationship on what it means for
notions of humanity of human rights and
of animal rights and kind of the border
between humans and other animals in my
case in the countryside in the 16th 17th
and 18th centuries I don't find much
evidence of an effective relationship
between humans and animals and other
animals we don't have a lot of examples
of pet keeping in the countryside and
that's curious and I and I think it's I
think that's important for two reasons
one it shows us that that effective
relationship between humans and other
animals it is a historical relationship
that has to be contextualized it did not
always exist so we have to understand
when it emerged why and where the other
thing is that I think it points us to
the fact that animals served really
important crucial economic function sure
in the country so when they were
dependent on their livelihood exactly
and an animal labor and so that was one
of the things that that's one of the
ways that my work sort of diverges from
some of the other work on human animal
relations that really focus on these
affective relationships and then also
kind of the philosophical implications
of thinking about animals as historical
subjects
I was really interested in this book in
the kind of productive laboring and
economic functions of animals that said
dogs do play a role in my book a big
role so I have two chapters on ok so
tell us about the dogs ok so I'm going
to make me cry so the first thing to say
is that it's very common these sort of
the the commonplace thing that you hear
is that in Muslim societies in Islam
dogs are considered virtually impurity
read even from the time of the Prophet
himself so there's a there's a body of
literature that is a collection of the
sayings and doings of the Prophet as
related by his companions ok ok so if
you read and this is a very important
body of literature in in the scholarship
on the history of Islam if you read the
even that body of literature there are
some accounts that say the Prophet
himself prayed in the presence of dogs
some of his companions kept dogs that
actually if a Muslim saw a dog while
praying it would not invalidate his or
her prayer and then there are there are
accounts that contradict that but the
important thing to say is that it's a
mixed bag it's not all bad it's not all
good but it's also not all bad mm-hmm ok
so that's the first point to make moving
on from you know the times of the
Prophet if you know so thinking about
literature produced between the 10th and
the 12th century about dogs we have lots
of accounts about the wonderful
attributes of dogs their loyalty their
trustworthiness dogs sacrificing to save
humans they're productive functions for
controlling herds for providing security
and cities so again a very a very
positive take on the presence of dogs in
society and very little actually about
their impurity or
that there are negative presence in
society they also serves a very
productive function in major cities in
the Middle East and you know some of the
oldest cities in the world are in the
Middle East and the main productive
function that they served beyond
security was consuming garbage
so they actually served a sort of Public
Health and hygiene function by eating
garbage in the cities and we see this in
other cities around the world in various
periods of dogs and other animals
consuming garbage in cities so in New
York City in the nineteenth century for
example hogs were very important for
keeping streets clean and and so in the
ottoman period for example in Cairo and
in Istanbul and in other cities we have
accounts of Ottoman authorities in
cities actually putting out food for
dogs providing water troughs for them
court cases of punishing people who
committed violence against dogs so again
a recognition that dogs played an
integral role in human societies and
that that role was important and had to
be supported so that's the good part of
the story this that there's a transition
in this relationship between humans and
dogs and specific in that in the early
19th century various processes came to
change this relationship one of them was
increasing urbanization and increasing
urban populations so there was a thing
about Cairo and specific here there was
a a pressure placed on on space inside
the city and as part of that garbage was
moved outside of the city okay as part
of this process that the second thing
that sort of reinforced this change in
the human dog relationship it was a
changing ideas about disease and where
disease came from so the early 19th
century in Cairo this is the period in
which we begin to see ideas that disease
came from rotting rotting
rotting entities that produced this bad
air right and that breathing that air
would cause one to get sick so these
writing entities included garbage they
could be dank ponds swampy areas rotting
flesh this is also a moment in which
cemeteries are moved outside of Cairo so
moving the garbage mounds outside of the
city meant that the sort of integral
role that dogs played of consuming this
garbage was no longer exigent there was
no longer a need for dogs inside the
city to consume this garbage because the
garbage had been moved outside of the
city and those former places were now
made into homes and businesses and other
things there and so this means that also
in this period there's a shift towards a
different solution to the problem of
urban sanitation and garbage collection
in that there were certain urban
populations of humans who became the
main garbage collectors in Cairo in this
period so a kind of if you like
replacement of the former labouring role
of dogs in taking care of garbage inside
the city moving from dogs to humans
right okay so in doing in doing your
research did you find anything that was
particularly surprising that you weren't
anticipating well I mean I think just
the sheer sort of presence of different
classes of animals and we've we barely
touched on the third class of animals
that I was interested in charismatic
megafauna okay which were the lions and
tigers and elephants and giraffes and
things that were a part of sovereignty
and the hunt and those sorts of things
so I was just sort of really impressed
with the sheer amount of archival
material about animals I mean this is
not a topic that has been worked on very
much in Ottoman history and in the
Middle East I mean they're they're some
important important works but for the
most part you know this topic has been
ignored but you know when you when you
start reading the sources you realize
that
there's just an enormous amount of
material on this topic and I only
scratched the surface I mean there are
various things that you know that
there's just so you know too much for
one person to undertake and and you know
I think and when one of the points that
I made in the book is that this should
not be a surprise to us given the
centrality of animals to all these
laboring and economic and social and
political functions that I've gotten
into and that we should we should take
this relationship seriously because it's
of enormous historical importance so I
think that was sort of the main thing
that that surprised me in doing okay so
so basically what do you conclude in the
book okay so the main thing that I want
readers to take away from the book is to
understand that the human animal
relationship is historically contingent
and that it changed over time and the
specific change that I'm interested in
tracking over the course of my book is a
transition around the turn of the 19th
century so roughly from let's say you
know 1750 to 1850 and this is a
transition in the human animal
relationship and it's a transition in
the kind of economic history and
political history of Egypt's place in
the Ottoman Empire and this is a
function of a more global transition
that lots of societies are undertaking
and this has usually been glossed as
something like commercialization or the
age of revolutions capitalism and so
that those kinds of transitions are also
happening in Egypt and for me the
human-animal relationship that the
economic role of animals and how that
changes is part and parcel of that story
so I want to understand how the
dialectic relationship between those
those processes capitalism
commercialization modernization state
formation and the human animal
relationship and the general story in a
very broad brushstroke that I tell is
one of
of going from a society in which human
animal relations are integral to economy
society politics to one in which they're
no longer central one in which animals
are no longer the the the major motoring
force of society right a world in which
dogs are no longer the main means of
public hygiene in in urban societies a
world in which these charismatic
megafauna are used in very different
ways and that story is one of the
emergence of the zoo as an institution
and kind of the modern trade in animals
which again is it's big business and
continues to this day so again going
from a world in which there's kind of an
integral relationship between humans and
animals and all these different spheres
into one in which animals are still
integral but in which they are there
they are no longer at the center of
society and become marginalized in
various kinds of ways and so what are
the economic political and social
implications of that marginalization
very good fascinating actually thank you
so much for being here today with us and
sharing some of your work for more
information about Professor Mikhail and
his work please visit our website at
Yale edu slash Macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale